these Tigers that they're producing are
worthless to the wild they're not
genetically fit and not behaviorally fit
to be reintroduced the while Netflix is
the tiger king murder mayhem and madness
gives viewers a look into the world of
big cat ownership in America along with
murder plots and uh nairo neck leather
fringe but in the drama it's easy to
lose sight of what's actually happening
big cats being bred sold and treated as
if they were everyday pets and these
captive bred animals will never be
released
they're no more useful to Tigers in the
wild and domestic nerves are two roles
in wild to find out what captive
breeding does these endangered and
threatened animals we talked to dr. John
Goodrich a chief scientist at Panthera
the global wild cat conservation
organization before we get into the
problems of captive breeding we hear the
figure a lot that there are more tigers
in captivity net States than there are
actually living in the wild I was when
if there's any truth in uh how hard is
it to quantify actually how many Tigers
are here given that this is a black
market you hear the number of five to
ten thousand tigers in captivity in the
United States nobody really knows but
it's probably in the right order of
magnitude there's only about 4,000
tigers left in the in the wild but the
problem is there's no tracking of these
Tigers every single Tiger should be
identified and tracked from its birth to
its death it's not a hard thing to do
and tigers are walking barcodes there
each one is identified individually by
their stripes it's like a fingerprint
and one of the arguments that these
captive breeders make is that you know
if we're having populations crash in the
wild why not read them in captivity and
reintroduce them why is that wrong
headed there's two things that happen
with these captive bred Tigers and and
they're opposites
one is is inbreeding low genetic
diversity and that's primarily in white
tigers all white tigers in captivity
come from a single white tiger captured
in India decades ago so you can imagine
those Tigers are very inbred but then
the opposite happens where there's
interbreeding among subspecies of tigers
and they and they even hybrid his eyes
tigers with lions and other species so
that makes these
sort of genetic months that are not of
any use whatsoever in conservation there
are a number of different extent
subspecies of tigers in the wild there's
the Siberian tiger up in Russia and
northern China Indo Chinese tiger and in
Thailand Malaysia and Malaysia Sumatran
tiger in Indonesia and then the Bengal
tiger in South Asia they have different
adaptations to their unique environments
so you wouldn't want to take a Siberian
tiger for example and reintroduce it you
know from the colds of Russia to hot
tropics of India or some watcher
likewise you wouldn't want to take a
tiger that's either been severely inbred
from captivity or or out bred some of
these hybrids and reintroduce it and
pollute the genetics of the existing
water populations beyond the genetics
why would it be so problematic to
reintroduce a tiger raised in captivity
into the wild just based on the
behaviors that it has developed as it
has grown up especially some of these
Tigers from petting zoos or even some of
the rescue centers they have an awful
lot of exposure to people people are
coming by visiting them every day people
are feeding them every day and they
learn to associate people with food and
people they associate people with play
and all sorts of things so if you were
to release one of those tigers into the
wild in India for example where you
might have hundreds of people per square
miles surrounding the the National Park
or Tiger Reserve where you've released
them you can imagine those Tigers are
just going to go right to people looking
for food looking for entertainment
whatever and then you'd have a big
problem on your hands when people and
tigers don't mix well all tigers are too
big and too dangerous our conservation
groups breeding Tigers in a certain way
such that they can be reintroduced to
the wild and not corrupt the gene pool
zoos that are accredited by a za the
Association for zoos and aquariums in
North America are required to be part of
what they call the Species Survival
program so any Tigers and those zoos are
bred very carefully to maintain their
genetics to maintain their sub species
status but also to guard against
inbreeding theoretically we could take
Tigers from zoos build a captive
breeding center
and then start to breed Tigers so that
cubs were produced that were exposed to
the natural wild habitats exposed to
natural prey and hopefully could
eventually be reintroduced into the wild
but we really don't want to get there
you know that's the absolute last ditch
effort if it comes to reintroductions
it's a bit of a Hail Mary how does it
program at a zoo that is maintaining
Tigers different from what we're seeing
in a show like Tiger King first do's are
not breeding Tigers for sale they are
breeding Tigers to maintain that genetic
stock in captivity
these petting zoos are breeding Tigers
to make money so they're trying to pump
out as many cups as they can remember
the Cubs are only worth anything to them
in the petting zoo until they're about
four months old and then they become too
dangerous for the public to handle what
happens to all those Tigers we don't
know that's a big concern
Tigers breed really well in captivity so
it's easy for people to take them breed
them produce more Tigers and everybody
wants that selfie with a tiger cub so
that compounds the problem but you can
imagine this animal you know in the wild
Tigers need anywhere from ten to
hundreds of square miles that they cover
over the course of the year of their
home range and you can imagine an animal
that should be wandering over that kind
of area in lush forests being kept in a
small cage they don't do too well you
know so one of the things that the
accredited zoos do beyond trying to have
natural habitat large enough enclosures
they do an awful lot of enrichment where
they're putting different scents around
the cage every day giving them to the
animals different toys to play with
different things to explore so the
animals are constantly stimulated in
ways they might be stimulated in their
natural habitat can you walk us through
what conservation actually looks like
out in the wild all Tigers need is lots
of in violent space with good habitat
high prey densities and to be left alone
by people and they thrive Tigers are
most threatened by habitat loss and
especially poaching
Tigers are approached because they're
extremely valuable on the traditional
medicine market so while the recipe for
a tiger conservation is simple actually
implementing it can be pretty
challenging Tigers
live in some of the most remote rugged
and difficult parts of the world to
access so the patrol teams that are out
there trying to protect tigers from
poaching have a really tough job ahead
of them and just finding the poachers
capturing the poachers and then once
captured he might be a week's walk into
a forest you've got to take them back
out so it's a it's a pretty challenging
task and what about legal protections
here for Tigers the United States so
Tigers are on the United States and
dangerous species act and that gives
them a certain amount of protection but
what that means is they can't be traded
internationally and they can't be traded
across state borders at the state level
many states have laws against owning big
cats and other wildlife species is but
many states allow it openly so there is
legislation being pushed right now to
make it illegal for private ownership
with big cats in the United States you
know an idea well what can we do with
those Tigers do we put them in better
homes in the United States are there
enough of those given that this black
market is so big would it be able to
hold all of them it's a really tough
problem if we were to pass legislation
today that banned ownership of tigers
there's a number of different ways that
could go you could start a phase-out
period or maybe first these places are
all required to spay and neuter their
animals and and then when their last
animal finally dies they close down if
we were to just close it down and try to
find homes for all those tigers were you
gonna put in there's you know there's a
lot of rescue centers around the country
most of those are at capacity already so
the next choice would be to euthanize
them the way we do with an awful lot of
our surplus dogs and cats and that of
course would be tragic but the cost of
maintaining these tigers is also
absorbing and you know for the million
dollars that costs per year to run a
rescue center we could protect so many
tigers in the wild so there's trade-offs
too it's it's a real moral dilemma do
you have any advice for as to how people
can be smarter of finding good parks
it's pretty simple actually you can just
look for zoos that are accredited by the
ACA and the ACA has them listed on their
website if it's not on the list doesn't
necessarily mean it's a bad sue but then
you'll need to dig deeper I mean if you
get two takes
selfies with the tiger if you get to
touch them then no that's not a good
establishment I wonder if you had any
insights as to how you might be able to
tell if that tiger has been mistreated
in captivity some obvious physical signs
might be a tiger that's extremely
staying or extremely fat or maybe shows
some evidence of injuries but beyond
that you can learn a lot from their
behavior if a tiger looks peaceful and
content it's probably peaceful and
content if it's pacing around its cage
and showing other kinds of neurotic
behaviors then it's probably in too
small the cage is not receiving enough
stimulus we're gonna know the answer to
this question but would a tiger ever
make a good pet absolutely not think
about having a 400 pound cat with three
inch canines and three-inch claws in
your living room or in your backyard
even a well-mannered completely non
aggressive individual obviously an
animal that big with that kind of
weaponry could convert hurt you without
even trying